Tony Stark should be in jail yep you
heard me I am totally serious when you
go back and watch all the movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Tony Stark
breaks law after law after law just by
being Iron Man Don't believe me I'm
about to prove it to you
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that wants you to snap that
subscribe button away you know loyal
theorists not sure I've ever seen a
franchise go on such a roller coaster of
quality and discourse as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe across the last three
years once held up as this Beacon of
real consistent quality in an industry
where Blockbusters were often garbage
cash grabs the quality of the MCU has
become mid at best phase four had a lot
of Ops sure but it also had a lot of
really down Downs confusing and
convoluted plots baffling creative
decisions cool ideas and character arcs
that just seem to be completely
abandoned before we hit their Peak
honestly after watching the movie that
was Ant-Man quantumania made me go back
and re-watch the older MCU films trying
to identify where and what exactly went
wrong if you want to see what I think
happened well you can check out our
video telling Marvel that it's time to
panic but as I was binging Iron Man yet
again something else dawned on me
something that completely
re-contextualized the mcu's first and
biggest hero suddenly I realized that
Tony Stark yeah he wasn't as heroic as I
thought he was this dude should be in
prison multiple times over Tony Stark
Was a Serial womanizer a liar to
everyone around him and an arms dealer
responsible for potentially hundreds of
thousands of deaths before he ever had
the idea of a futuristic suit of armor
he's hoarded world changing technology
like the nanotech that powers the suit
and end game for his self and his
friends and that's not even mentioning
how he teams up with the US government
to create the department of damage
control exploiting the destruction that
he himself causes with the Avengers to
further profit himself his actions led
to the creation of villains like the
Iron Monger Whiplash the vulture the
fake Mandarin Baron Zemo and do I even
need to mention Ultron who killed
thousands in sokovia Tony Stark is a man
who has a lot to answer for heck even
the Iron Man franchise itself agrees
with that statement so many of the
franchises stories are about Tony
atoning for his mistakes and Tony
himself feels massive guilt for all of
it later in his life and while all of
this is awful painting a picture of a
deeply flawed man in desperate need of
some therapy it doesn't hold a candle to
the actual laws that Tony breaks
seriously as I was re-watching these
movies I started to wonder how Tony
Stark would fare in the real world with
our real world legal system superhero or
no throughout the MCU the sins of Tony
Stark have added up let me tell you it
wouldn't be looking good for the
Invincible Iron Man if he did eventually
have have his day in court that's right
friendos today we're tackling a theorist
classic the good guy is bad actually by
the end of this you'll never look at
Iron Man the same way again and the big
twist the thing that would have really
ruined Tony Stark it boils down to four
tiny words I am Iron Man power up your
Arc reactors loyal theorists let's get
into it so to begin we're gonna start
with the quote unquote small laws that
Tony breaks throughout his career to
start let's look at Iron Man 3 and how
Stark's Vendetta against the Mandarin
probably led him into multiple state and
federal crimes especially that whole
action set piece where he breaks into
the mandarins compound first of all a
lot of the improvised weapons that he
creates for this raid would have been
illegal specifically I'm thinking about
all those explosives that he creates
from everyday supplies that he bought at
Home Depot it's a federal crime to
possess any unregistered explosive
devices which could carry a maximum
federal penalty of 10 years in prison
why count these and not the missiles in
the Iron Man suit well he as a defense
contractor likely did register those
explosives and all the little bombs from
Iron Man 3 those were made under the
radar and he did definitely didn't have
time to file the paperwork there
additionally when Tony steals one of the
guard's guns and then threatens Trevor
and the group he's with it that would
have counted as multiple crimes just
pointing a gun at someone is considered
aggravated assault and it can result in
five years in prison and five years
probation but possession of an illegal
gun in Florida and he definitely had
that gun legally Tony just straight up
stole it could mean that he's facing
another ten thousand dollars in fines
and 15 years in prison but honestly
Stark jumped the fence to confront the
Mandarin here in the first place likely
would have been its own crime normally
I'd call this breaking and entering but
this part of the movie actually takes
place in Miami Florida and that state
doesn't consider breaking and entering
its own crime Instead This would have
been classified as something more severe
first degree burglary because Tony
illegally entered a building with the
intent to commit a criminal offense he
then assaulted someone while inside
there and then likely caused more than a
thousand dollars in property damage with
those explosive Christmas ornaments in
short this would be up to ten thousand
dollars in fines and 30 years in prison
so things are already legally shaky for
old Tony Stark but all of that is in
pursuit of a known criminal in
international terrorist is there
anything else more serious that we can
pit on Tony absolutely look no further
than the Avengers which sees Tony off
alone hacking government computers to
get information he wasn't supposed to
have what are you doing Mr Stark kind of
been wondering the same thing about you
what is phase two first of all
trespassing on federal government
property without expressed permission
can be a serious offense I see this
going one of two ways the Helicarrier
could be considered a military base in
which case Tony would be subject to six
months in jail and or a 500 fine or it
would be akin to trespassing in a
federal building similar to the U.S
Capitol which would be a misdemeanor
punishable by six months in prison or a
five thousand dollar fine also depending
on how important the government deems a
high-ranking military official like Nick
Fury Tony could be in a lot more trouble
in that case this trespassing would
become a Class E felony and he'd be
behind bars for up to five years you
know a 250 000 fine but even worse than
all of that would be Tony's hacking of
military computers on the Helicarrier
this would be a textbook violation of
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act which
makes it a federal crime to gain
unauthorized access to protected
government computers in fact it makes it
illegal to even attempt or conspire to
do that hacking if charged with a crime
Tony would be facing up to a year in
federal prison if this is deemed a
lesser offense in all likelihood he'd
probably be charged for a serious
offense and given 10 to 20 years since
the hacking involves some very sensitive
National Security information you know
what else what let's actually double
this since we also see Tony hacking into
a national security contractor's
database in Iron Man 3 and Captain
America Civil War where he hacks the
rafts microphones and cameras I mean my
man can't go more than a movie or two
without breaking into secure government
computers but in the Avengers Tony was
doing his best to defend New York in all
of Earth from Loki a few cyber crimes
here and sneaking around there is
justifiable right maybe but you know
it's a lot harder to justify how much he
endangers Peter Parker by giving Peter
the stark-built Spidey equipment and
then encouraging him to go out crime
fighting to the point that Peter
literally died out in space Tony
definitely broke a few laws there now
surprisingly I wasn't able to find
anything specific about being the cause
of death for a minor out in space at the
hands of a giant purple raisin man no
laws currently on the books about that
one I'm afraid but it is a crime in New
York to endanger the welfare of anyone
who's 16 years of age and younger
between Civil War Spider-Man homecoming
and infinity War Peter's around 14 to 16
years old so he definitely qualifies
here and Tony bringing him into the
world of crime fighting given equipment
and encouraging vigilante justice that
right there definitely qualifies
Adventure now even if he is telling
Peter that he needs to be better and
safer this is still a Class A
misdemeanor punishable by up to a year
in jail it's also just a really bad look
for Tony to be honest another really bad
look pretty much everything that Tony
does with Peter in Civil War first off
he takes custody of a child under false
pretenses and definitely takes him
across International borders illegally
according to the U.S Department of
Homeland Security Customs and Border
Protection while miners can travel
internationally without a parent or
legal guardian many destinations require
notarized written consent from their
parents given that she didn't even know
that Peter was Spider-Man Aunt May
definitely did not give her consent for
Peter to go get beat up by Captain
America in a German airport and even if
she did Peter doesn't have the paperwork
necessary for the trip you got a
passport no and this would be a serious
crime for Tony in fact it would probably
have been defined as human trafficking
though that term is most often connected
with very dark real world tragedies
according to the DHS human trafficking
can also include the use of fraud or
coercion to obtain labor and traffickers
might use manipulation or false promises
of well-paying jobs to lure victims in
a stewardship a position in The Avengers
that sure sounds like manipulation to
get Spidey overseas all while putting
him in the sights of trained soldiers
thieves Sorcerers and assassins in a
fight that left someone outright
paralyzed for Life yeah that's really
not good there Tony human trafficking is
a federal crime with a punishment that
could include anywhere between 20 years
and life in prison even after Tony dies
to save the universe from Thanos he's
still performing Lee Lee Shady acts with
Peter specifically leaving him the Edith
glasses just in case you don't remember
these give Peter control over Stark's
defense satellite system as well as some
super dangerous drones it is wild now
it's obviously difficult to find a
one-to-one case in the real world since
we don't have armies of killer drones
controlled by AI glasses so we're gonna
use similar laws for guns instead in the
United States you are allowed to leave
your weapons to an error after you die
but all guns bequeathed in this way are
subject to the National Firearms Act of
1932 as well as the revised version of
the gun control Act of 1968. according
to these law us you have to register
certain heavy duty weapons with the
government before you can leave them to
an air Additionally the NFA also
requires that the permanent transport of
NFA Firearms across state lines be
reported Peter didn't even know the
glasses controlled these killer drones
until after he left the U.S so they'd be
labeled as Contraband in the eyes of the
United States they legally could not
have been passed to an heir and should
have instead been considered abandoned
by Stark after his death and handed over
to the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
firearms and explosives and that's not
even me mentioning that the sort of
automatic Weaponry used in the drones
are just straight up illegal in the
European Union countries that they're
visiting and far from home to be fair
Tony was dead at this point and wouldn't
have seen Justice for his crime but
still this is another No-No that Tony
definitely did did and while the Edith
drones were certainly sketchy the Iron
Man suits themselves likely would also
be illegal too guns aren't the only
thing that can be counted as regulated
weapons the suits would absolutely be
something that the government would
likely want some oversight on I mean
sure these things might be humanoid
shaped and called suits and they
certainly have more in common with an
Abrams tank than an Armani suit believe
it or not but there are actually
regulations in the US about whether or
not you can own an operational tank
because tanks have weapons with bores or
barrels that are wider than three
quarters of an inch a National Firearms
Act classifies them as destructive
weapons though Tony suits mostly use
Repulsor or energy weapons which side
note we should probably do a theory
about that at some point right like what
are repulsors are they real and if they
are are they legal either way Repulsor
weapons would absolutely fit that same
destructive weapon category as such Tony
would have to get a permit to even own
his Iron Man suits which really doubt
that the government would want to give
him at least first memories basically a
rogue agent throughout Iron Man 1. and
the government outright wants to
confiscate all his technology in Iron
Man 2. and any violation of the National
Firearms act as a felony punishable by a
fine of up to 250 000 and up to 10 years
in prison and on top of being considered
something equivalent to a tank the Iron
Man suits would also likely be
considered personal aircraft since the
Federal Aviation administer situation
considers any craft weighing more than
254 pounds and flying faster than 63
miles per hour as an ultralight aircraft
legally speaking all of the Iron Man
suits might have to be registered as
small private airplanes if that's the
case the fact that Tony's flying them
through populated urban areas cities
like New York that is absolutely
unacceptable even Stark entering space
like we see in Infinity War would likely
be against the law since you actively
need permits from a space-faring nation
to enter the atmosphere within their
airspace all of this would cause the FAA
to find Tony another fifty thousand to
four hundred thousand dollars per
violation even if Tony was somehow able
to clear all these hurdles file all the
correct paperwork and get approved for
all the iron Manning we see throughout
the franchise we know that there are
still times that he's operated his suits
criminally during Tony's lowest point in
Iron Man 2 when he thinks that he's
dying and throws a party in his
depression he wears the suit while
clearly under the influence of alcohol
now this is really bad and since we've
deduced that the suits likely count as
some sort of vehicle this would be the
equivalent of reading a dangerous
vehicle while Under the Influence this
scene takes place in Tony's house in
Malibu and if we're specifically talking
about planes which remember the Iron Man
suits would qualify as flying while
under the influence in California
carries a mandatory 30-day to six month
jail sentence up to 15 years in prison
and up to 250 000 in fines additionally
Tony accidentally and then intentionally
discharges his weapons while at the
party
did you see how close he came to hitting
those innocent people just there to have
a good time this would have
AB count as negligent discharge of a
firearm it could either be counted as a
misdemeanor or a felony it also carries
a sense of up to three years in jail so
that's a massive laundry list of crimes
that Tony's committed over the years
under the guise of helping people just
for my account here he'd be facing
upwards of 174 years in prison and finds
in excess of one million one hundred and
seventy one thousand dollars and that's
just from the few things that I brought
up here that we see in the movies now
the money yeah we all recognize that
that doesn't matter he's a billionaire
it's a drop in the bucket for him as for
whether or not he'd actually spend that
time in prison well he probably should
but the American legal system can be an
imperfect place especially when you're
talking about high profile wealthy
individuals so is that it after
everything that we've listed out here
today between assault hacking
endangering a minor operating the legal
equivalent of a flying tank while Under
the Influence would all of this just be
a mild inconvenience for Tony Stark a
legal bump in the road that he can make
go away by paying his fines and winning
a jury to his side no loyal theorists
Tony makes one final match of mistake
that would have ruined his life or at
least destroyed his career as Iron Man
and it's right here truth is
I am Iron Man this iconic moment that
basically started the biggest movie
franchise in history would have
absolutely stopped Tony Stark in his
tracks why because the government would
now know that he is in fact Iron Man see
some of the laws that Tony breaks
throughout his run in the MCU have other
punishments Beyond just fines and jail
time for example any violation of the
National Firearms Act means that the
weapon involved is forfeit and can be
confiscated by the government so just
owning one of these operational Iron Man
suits without a permit from the US
government would likely mean that the
government could take the suits and Tony
would have no legal recourse but the
craziest thing they wouldn't actually
need any hard evidence that Tony had
broken any laws civil forfeiture is a
process where law enforcement can seize
the assets of a person suspected of a
crime without actually charging them and
if Tony were to successfully fight that
in court and get his armor back well
then the government could play an UNO
reverse card and use eminent domain
which allows them to pay Stark what they
consider to be a fair amount for the
armor and still take it without his
consent and if you think they wouldn't
do this not like Tony's good graces of
the U.S federal government for a lot of
his run as hero we actually see the the
U.S government acting on at least one of
these inside the movies in Iron Man 2
the Senate is holding hearings about
whether or not Stark should hand over
the Iron Man weapon for the good of the
U.S to get the Iron Man weapon turned
over to the people of the United States
of America well you can forget it and as
soon as Tony starts acting irresponsible
in public Roadie takes one of the suits
on behalf of the U.S military probably
using exactly one of these laws none of
this would have been possible if the
government had no proof no leads that
Tony Stark was Iron Man and what did
Tony do I am Iron Man he confessed not
only to owning the equivalent of a
flying tank bragging about it in front
of Congress on International TV but also
to every crime committed while using the
suits Tony Stark and his hubris ruined
himself with those four little iconic
words because if the government didn't
know he was Iron Man well he couldn't
charge him with any Iron Man crimes just
looking at this laundry list Tony's life
is so comically over the top illegal
that there has to be some explanation
for how he isn't rotting Behind Bars
maybe just maybe all the favors that he
makes for the government later on in the
franchise keeping war machine up to date
signing the sokovia Accords helping him
found the department of damage control
here that's him performing some
community service for the government to
avoid jail time but I suppose that's a
theory for another day and as always my
friends remember it's all just a theory
a film Theory
and cut